in the previous episode they've created
condenser machines to open a rift to
what lies beyond been the batteries
Titans world something happened last
night
entities got through the rift and we
couldn't shut down the condenser
everybody in the building was
slaughtered they called mass for your
help I told them you were just a child
that it was too dangerous but they know
only you know how to deal with what lies
beyond the rift Oh
it's my girl house to go and rest -
welcome back to another episode of
beyond 2 souls Oh
snipe wait they can't go inside
the can open doors they can shake their
booty
I mean heads but the cane open nose
alright the epic journey continues I
wonder what we're gonna find on the
other side things are so mysterious
maybe like an angel angel hasty but
that's what I think I don't think a lot
of people care well I look like an angel
look at this brightness a.m. and my fat
got shut up here okay no one cares okay
so that's a lot of them isn't it holy
[ __ ] Kat reminds me of the matrix you
know those that the person
No yeah I think I nailed that they
opened the rift that looks like
something else either side looks like a
magical person the same
so now Aiden can go in that's what he
wanted right and that's what Jodie wants
you just want to be normal my god it's
like uh what do you want mitad oh I need
to go Aidan and move him gotcha
apparently not well [ __ ] what do I know
about life there we go well it's not
working
don't you think anyone try that before
though
it's sort of console
wait no Jodi Jodi no you're crazy
I don't what you're smoking that sure is
hailing kind of work that's in the name
of my boobs being called Berta and Benny
that [ __ ] ain't kind of work okay I'm
gonna make a run for the console well I
run you protect me from the entities see
I have to do all the hard work but fine
let's go all right have fun hey wait you
run I'm controlling the running I gotta
do everything done nice parenting breath
oh [ __ ]
uh-oh
ah get away from out get away from Jody
you black [ __ ] gaba what am i do so
badass I just don't understand
yeah what the [ __ ] are you oh I killed
it
how did I do that yeah yeah got my dog
all excited what's up home now you
trying to nap what IRA cold well
there's bound to be more than two of
them keep running
let's keep running I love the pirouette
she does okay left no that was wrong way
apparently how the [ __ ] am I supposed to
help
I think I kill that
these are harder to kill it gets got a
squeeze them squeeze or slap either way
is good for my rap the guy should be
PewDiePie raps that's my new channel
yeah god
they're scary
okay it's up here right
damn oh no come on you can do it Eddie
can do it Eddie
I'm trying and its iDEN I mean Aidan
[ __ ] go up coke on him get up get up get
out of my head
why do I know Dan lyrics Anna come on it
looks pretty awesome this room gotta say
I like liked it
oh [ __ ] wrong way right no it's right
way okay
why didn't want to open the rift anyway
oh [ __ ] we have to do come on Jody you
can do it you can do it Jody - fireworks
anyone else want to come fireworks you
do
it's really I don't know what I'm gonna
wake ah
anyone else didn't think so
come on Joey we got this you got this
[ __ ] in our book
we don't have a book yet but I'm sure we
will be a best-seller
I don't know buy you birds but I would
probably call it a little faster if I
was in danger of my life
I mean just random con X that [ __ ]
badass what is he gonna do
she cray she cry made ah yes anyone else
oh [ __ ] ah
ah yes third one for whatever get silly
ah come on
oh [ __ ] what happened I don't think I
got it
Bush there we go Oh where my mamma mia
pizzeria that wasn't licensed come on
get up get up get up not falling down in
that vagina what
hell yeah [ __ ] hi guy oh we weren't
even supposed to go there we were
supposed to go that we just read the
bridge that's all we did
man Ukraine Ukraine a day doubled crane
hell yeah
see we're not waiting to come this far
to stop down
there's a door then open that would be
offered
I wish we got the pole they always make
you do stuff we only need to pull the
lever
I would shout out in the microphone
oh damn Oh
is she gonna get sucked in no yeah oh
that's very bad I didn't help her
come on she's gonna get stuck in the red
no no no she did it she cray
high-five this nail let good job
damn oh did he get sucked in huh is that
what happened I didn't know are you
there huh
interesting yeah cuz we didn't really
see her in yet
wha so she did care about him well I
guess that happens when you spend enough
time with me hey I was here all along
baby boo
you don't even know what he is he could
be like really really ugly you wouldn't
even know about it
hey Jodi it's all my fault
my god I was so afraid I lost you
don't let them ever do that again
if they open a passage ya be nothing
left I am
so I don't know their their relationship
it's kind of awkward in my opinion
what are you resting I mean I like that
at the fall and all and I like I ship
them as as daughter and father can you
ship daughters and fathers no hi
it's weird enough ok ok so I'm supposed
to show these because these are the
timeline which I'm feeling idiot that I
didn't think of I thought of it I just
never processed it you know I'm saying
that is the ugly snowman again he's back
and he's furious that Koontz call him
ugly
there is really a vast improvement from
looking at Quantic Dream's games from
their very first one which I don't
remember what is called two Fahrenheit
and then Fahrenheit to heavy rain and
then hammering to this it's kind of cool
to see that dad huge improvement is it's
what kind of make me keep one I play
their games in the future I don't know
it's it's cool
and now we're on the run again that is
very very cold could an I didn't hide
heat up some soup maybe where we going
out now well the cops just passed like I
guess AB hey thanks because it reminds
you a lot of Fahrenheit but not wow it's
so [ __ ] right I'm sorry about that
and not only in the style but also the
settings like this totally feels like
Fahrenheit to me if you don't know what
fire 9 is and then it you must be very
confused it's a metric system no it's
not hey you found a sock thank you huh
don't really know where we're going whoa
whoa did we bring something back what
did the [ __ ] on a dog
what the [ __ ] are you guys the one maybe
she's dying and other people are trying
to take over our body now that's silly
Pitts you're silly
oh oh maybe I'm not so wrong after all
maybe I'm a [ __ ] genius all right go
go power ring oh that's the guy we saw
in the beginning you both remember it is
it's gonna affect our life come on man
she's right there come on you gotta save
her aah
they're trying to getting her Liddy do
what everybody goddamn ups can we do
there my wake the [ __ ] up man she's
right there she's right there that is
not the man in the beginning my bad
you look different
Rose remember fat can I spoil Fahrenheit
one second that part where all the
homeless people were protectors the
dumbest [ __ ] ever just want to point
that out it was really fair I was really
good in the beginning I kept I'm sorry
she keeps on talking about what Jody
what the [ __ ] are you doing
whoa that looks amazing my gosh it
damn Hey
oh it is him see how was right man I'm
smiling you never wake up where am I
my place good not very luxurious but hey
I like it quiet
finding the streets a few days ago we
were pretty bad shape you've been taking
care of me come on somebody had to good
leave you lying here dying like a dog in
the street kid ping it in and take her
to a hospital
understand
sup Stan your name dude
welcome back to lane eleven Jody nice to
have some company once in a while call
making routine nose strong there's like
[ __ ] but hold you up against the cold
thanks
giggles hot
telling you been on the streets kid
don't see everything your lighter annex
something like that about three years
for me how many times I thought I was
gonna snuff it feel completely nuts but
I guess you can get used to anything
even then with nothing
gotta run
mmm parents crazy boyfriend and then
like I said again I don't see a point of
lying no nothing
probably the law nicely it's nothing I
got that business so he's doing killed
somebody's fine by me
have you got someplace to go
family friends missing you yeah I guess
there is someone but I don't quiz that's
not like this who is that someone
what are you resting
stay barrel looks awfully suspicious I
got much to share but never against
yours he seems nice Thanks
so what's her plan exactly I was another
person here hi hi who the hell are you
nice teddy oh she's pregnant
nice chair
where is this
hey man
what
is that all you can do we heat your
hands you've risen from the dead yeah
welcome to our magical kingdom my lady
nice scarf
what the [ __ ]
there's a lot of people here hey nice
guitar breath that's here sorry okay
well he doesn't want to talk we're
supposed to be iDEN is that it we can
see their memories I know that but what
have we got here
it looks like we can go so I'll I'll see
why we should hang around for you birth
sink
kind of confused by all this
I guess we're going then huh
it's like we're going here
we got normal food left
I'm not let they got to do something
about it
and we see how things work around here
do we yeah yeah Oh Shh geez she doesn't
look too good
how does thing work around here
and that is ittle [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
snow
we need to make about five dollars
that's for something high I would try
here hopefully the coal to make people
feel more generous $5.00 my supposed to
sit too
it's home I'm so cold
Zittel it $5.00 on well depends on
people's good race
hi Wow ours took a week
ah now I feel like [ __ ] for never giving
money gonna have to hold on till we get
some cash think about something else
yes Stan
I don't think it makes sense both of us
being the same please
we will try it were there
good luck kid
he knows we're going away you could tell
so where are we trying our luck then
guys ugly
I see what a 3d origami killer seven
victims and still no lead hahahaha
that's awesome that's awesome
I heard someone tell me about if I come
across a guy reading a newspaper that's
awesome is it hot in those for a girl
she never asked for any of this burger
sound good but sucks pizza that's just
fuel it's so hard yeah life is so
difficult huh and I told him if you
didn't like it he can leave serves him
right
give give you some contrast on the world
breasts give you a fun contrast maybe
there's some money in the payphone nice
check oh there's a oh [ __ ]
why not but it's a bank I'm sorry but I
would take it yeah
it's a bank they got money okay let's go
see how Stan's doing well you brush and
tell me you wouldn't take the money
really really yeah I didn't think so
it's gone if you didn't have a
superpower that could give you money
like when you feed that don't make me
laugh ha ha Shh
Jordan would you give away kitsch well
you know I found it Johnny
if you stole that money it's not like
anyone was gonna miss him
this way we can eat tonight
tonight
so like I killed anybody for me
we could the game looks so good like I
gotta gotta hand it to them
why is he why is he trusting him with
money
how long do we have to wait
you win the lottery lucky son-of-a-bitch
that is disrespect with the homeless man
[ __ ] ed man
hey stay the [ __ ] away from him coffee
you won't get hurt
oh [ __ ] they're gonna fill me lookie
here it's like mom's got a girlfriend
it's demonstrate out okay [ __ ] it's
probably people oh I don't think so I
don't think so
anyone else nope nope nope nope nope
a lot of the guy just finished filming
what a [ __ ] idiot oh [ __ ] I didn't
know we don't need ID we're too awesome
[ __ ] what's wrong with people
Oh chef
oh it's on like Donkey Kong [ __ ]
hell he get the camera guy get the [ __ ]
is crazy
ceiling why don't you get the camera guy
are you that stupid how did you do that
I learned how to fight in the army
no but it was for them he's one of you
[ __ ] did not know how to fight let's
get out of here come back alright
all right Prez I hope you enjoyed
another episode of beyond 2 souls I'm
really glad you brought her into this
series it's a lot of fun for me to play
do whatever you want leave a like it
helps out a lot it comes to brofist you
ready you're telling me you're not ready
ok we go I'm not lying penny gonna be
like